-I do want to say
before we even start
this interview,
thank you so much.
You're one of the nicest guys
that I've ever worked with.
And you're very funny obviously
and we're going to get to
all of the fun jokes and stuff,
but seriously --
-You know that's bull[bleep].
I'm a dick.
[ Laughter ]
-No, you are not.
I just want to say,
you really are.
Thank you for doing --
You did me a solid.
You did an episode of
"Password."
-Yes, this Tuesday?
-This Tuesday.
-Yeah, guys, wait till
you see that Keke Palmer.
-That's exactly right.
That's the secret ingredient.
-She is a comedy alien.
-She's unbelievable, right?
-She pisses me off,
she's so funny.
[ Laughter ]
-Makes you mad? You're jealous?
-Yeah, at 28?
-Yeah, she's the greatest.
-I was still like,
"I should get a keg."
[ Laughter ]
-She's got it figured out.
-She is so funny.
-Yeah.
But thank you again
for doing that.
-Thank you for having me.
I would love to come back
and host it.
Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
-You just said
how great she was.
-Oh, look at that.
They're into it.
-No, they're not into it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You keep asking them.
-This is great.
-You were telling me backstage
that you just came back
from London,
which I do love London.
You went with the family?
-Oh, no, I didn't go.
I'm just kidding.
Yes. I'm sorry. Yes.
I have cousins that got
married -- not cousins.
I mean, they're cous--
They're not related.
-Wow.
They're royalty.
No.
So, happy wedding,
Brendan and Hannah.
Yes, it was beautiful.
It was great.
British weather. It was 104.
[ Audience groans ]
Yeah.
I was like,
you people live like animals.
But I drove for the first time
ever
on the left side of the road.
-Does that make you nervous?
-Yeah.
It was like training a cat.
It was all wrong.
I felt like I was playing Grand
Theft Auto, like, with a mirror.
[ Laughter ]
And I was so nervous.
And my kids were like,
"Can you turn on the music?"
I'm like, "No, I'm trying to
keep us alive."
[ Laughter ]
And then I got good at it.
Then I was just like,
"Watch this left turn."
And we're staying over here.
So, then I feel like my final
test was I drove through
Trafalgar Square
and Piccadilly Circus.
-Oh, my goodness.
-I had a couple of beers.
-No, no, no, that's not --
-Yeah, I was blasting Oasis.
-That's what you do in London.
Yeah, of course.
How old are the kids now?
-I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
-Ball park.
Ball park, ball park.
-They're 14 and 17.
-Yeah.
-And you know what teenagers
love?
Sightseeing.
[ Laughter ]
-No interest at all?
-We took them to
Stonehenge and they were like --
My 14-year-old was like,
"[Sarcastic] Wow.
Look at this pile of rocks.
Thank you.
This is really great."
[ Laughter ]
-Wow. I see they get
their sarcasm from Dad.
-Then we took them
to Salisbury Cathedral.
See?
And it's an enormous --
It's a beautiful church
that the poor built.
And my 14-year-old, again,
was like,
"I am not going in there.
There is no God."
No, he didn't say that.
But he was like,
"I don't want to go in there."
And then you go in there,
and he's like -- All the former,
you know, cardinals
or whatever are buried there.
It would be like
if Lorne Michaels was buried
in the "SNL" stage when he dies.
So, the 14-year-old was like,
"This is --" It is.
He was like, "This is very weird
that they bury people at work."
[ Laughter ]
-I understand, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-So he's like,
"Let's keep it moving.
And then my 17-year-old,
he's much more --
he's mellow and he's just like,
"Dad, you always know
how to say the wrong thing
at the worst time."
[ Laughter ]
And I was like,
"Yep, that's my kids."
-I saw you were all over
the Internet.
You know I follow you
on the socials too.
But you were all over
the Internet
because you did
this celebrity softball game.
-I did, yeah.
-At Dodger Stadium?
-Yeah, it was --
I thought it was just a local
Dodger celebrity game,
and it was not.
It was for All-Star Weekend.
I found out I replaced Rob Lowe.
So, that was a first.
And if you had told me when
"St. Elmo's Fire"
came out that that would happen,
I'd be like,
"I'm living the dream."
-You looked good, buddy.
I gotta say, I got a photo.
-I hit a home run.
And, oh, look. Yeah.
So, this is --
[ Cheers and applause ]
No, no. No, no, no.
-What do you mean?
-It was an
in-the-park home run.
If you play softball,
if you just keep running,
someone is going
to make a mistake.
And the ball
was flying all over the place.
I was like,
"Dreams are coming true."
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, man.
-Look, there's a Marvel star
right there.
So, I couldn't believe -- Yes,
it was better than the birth
of my kids, my marriage --
[ Audience ohs ]
-That's not true.
-I like how people are like,
"Oh, are you being serious?"
Yes. No.
[ Laughter ]
-You heard how sarcastic
his kids turned out to be.
Yeah, of course. Yeah.
I will say that you're getting
buzz off that,
because that was everywhere,
you and Bad Bunny,
I saw, were hanging out.
-Yeah, see, there you go.
I'm so old, I didn't --
They were like, "Bad Bunny is
going to be there."
I'm like,
"Sounds like a Funko Pop."
[ Laughter ]
And then he showed up --
[ Rim shot ]
How dare you?!
I just want to say I just got
rim-shot by an Oscar winner.
-Another dream come true.
-That's a dream come true
right there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Another dream.
The dreams keep coming true
for Joel McHale.
-This is -- No, and then --
And then when I told
my 14-year-old, I was like,
"Do you know who Bad Bunny is?"
And he was just like, "Ugh"
and then he walked
out of the room.
I was like, "I guess you do."
-That happened, then
you're on this show, by the way,
which I have not seen yet.
I know I'm going to love it.
-Thank you for being
honest though.
Because if you were like,
"I loved it"
and I was like, "Which part?"
you'd be like, "All of it."
[ Laughter ]
-I have not seen it yet.
It's called "The Bear."
-Oh, that one?
-Yeah.
-Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Oh, I haven't seen
your other show either.
[ Laughter ]
Don't worry about it.
I got things to do.
I'll get around to it.
A bunch of rocks and Stonehenge.
"The Bear."
I feel like this is made for me.
-You love cooking.
-I love cooking.
-I was in that show
for three minutes.
-I know.
It doesn't matter.
You could be the star.
-I really was.
And I literally have gotten
more response from that
than an entire year
on a sitcom on CBS.
[ Laughter ]
I am not kidding.
-I can't wait to watch it
because I know
I'm going to love it.
-I play a horrible person.
-Congrats on that.
-I mean the hero.
-A hero.
Let's talk about
"Celebrity Beef."
-"Celebrity Beef."
-This is a competition series.
You are the host.
You are the judge.
Can you set this up
for everybody?
-Yeah, this is my TED Talk.
This is an important show,
as you'll see.
It's very sophistica-- It's
basically celebrities cooking
and yelling at each other
over some small --
-So it's two celebrity friends,
and they just have a little --
-Some sort --
Rachel Harris and Cheryl Hines
were on.
-Cheryl Hines I saw a clip of.
-Yes.
And Rachel Harris always
changes hotel rooms,
and it really makes Cheryl mad.
So, that's the extent
of the argument.
It's not like,
"You killed my father."
-No, no, it's fun,
but it's cooking.
-It's screwing around.
-It's Joel McHale being quick
and funny, which you always are.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Joel McHale
in "Celebrity Beef."
Take a look at this.
-Now, this looks really good.
What the hell did you do?
First, it looked like some sort
of farming machine accident.
-It looked rough, like innards.
-And now it looks
absolutely perfect.
It goes a little bit
to the left, but still.
-"Celebrity Beef" airs
Tuesdays at 10:00 p.m. on E!
That's Joel McHale.
-Thank you.
-Zoey Deutch joins us
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.